the conservative party kind of pretended
to be ideological about austerity but if
you actually look at their behaviors but
they appear to be ideological about is
increasing inequality because
they were anti-austerity uh sorry they
were anti-deficit when a deficit meant a
welfare state when a deficit meant a
well-funded education system a welfare
NHS wealth under local councils then
they were anti-deficits when deficits
meant money to communities the people to
Services they were anti-deficit but when
a deficit means tax cuts for the rich
tax cuts for Bankers then suddenly
they're Pro deficit so I think and if
you if you look at what's happened to
inequality in the last 15 20 years you
know the conservative party happened to
move this way and that but they are
consistently massively increasing
inequality and you know I would
encourage the labor party and people on
the left to come back and fight that by
having a more
an understanding of the importance of
wealth and wealth distribution and who
has it because